this video is sponsored by conflict of
nations
the free online strategy game that
gathers millions of players worldwide
just as the romans did in their day your
objective is to take over the world
define your own strategy and build
powerful armies
by combining dozens of different unit
types such as nuclear submarines
tanks and stealth fighters okay so the
romans didn't have submarines and tanks
but you get the idea
you can play against up to 64 other
players in a real-time environment
in matches that can last up to weeks
with a player clan system that means you
can gang up on your opponents
so i have set up a special game of
conflict of nations for the first
viewers that click the link in the
description go to the website or app
type voices of the past in the search
bar and enter the password which
conveniently also is voices of the past
and you also get a special gift
click on the link below to get 13 000
gold and one month of premium
subscription for free choose a country
and fight your way to victory
[Music]
when has drubal the carthaginian
commander threw himself as a suppliant
at scipio's knees
the general turning to those around him
said
look my friends how well fortune knows
to make an example
of inconsiderate men this is that very
has trouble
who lately rejected the many kind offers
i made him and said that his native city
and her flames
were the most splendid obsequies for him
and here he is with suppliant boughs
begging for his life from me
and reposing all his hopes on me
some of the deserters now came forward
to the edge of the roof
and begged the front ranks of the
assailants to hold back for a moment and
when scipio gave this order
they began to abuse hazdribal some of
them for having violated his oath
saying that he had often sworn solemnly
that he would not desert them
and others for his cowardice and general
baseness of spirit
at this moment his wife seeing has
dribbled seated with scipio in front of
the enemy
came out from the crowd of deserters
herself dressed like a great lady
but holding her children who wore
nothing but their smocks
by each hand and wrapping them in her
cloak
at first she called on hazarable by his
name
but when he maintained silence and bent
his eyes to the ground
she began by calling on the gods and
expressing her deepest thanks to scipio
for sparing as far as he was concerned
not only herself
but her children then after a short
silence
she asked hasrable how without saying a
word to her
he had deserted them all and taken
himself to the roman general to secure
his own safety
how he had thus shamelessly abandoned
the state and the citizens who trusted
in him
had gone over secretly to the enemy and
how
he had the face to sit now beside the
enemy with suppliant bows in his hands
that enemy to whom he had often boasted
that the day would never dawn
on which the sun would look unhazarable
alive and his city
in flames
turning round to me at once and grasping
my hand
scipio said a glorious moment
polybius but i have a dread foreboding
that someday the same doom will be
pronounced
on my own country
zella is a town situated in pontus with
adequate natural defenses
considering its position in a plane for
its battlements are reared upon a hill
here farnasis repaired the ancient works
of his father's once prosperous camp
and occupied the position with his
entire forces
caesar pitched his camp five miles
distant from the enemy
and as he now saw that the valley by
which the king's camp was protected
would
if its width separated them equally
afford protection to a cap of his own
he ordered materials for a rampart to be
carted within the entrenchments
the following night he left camp at the
fourth watch
with all his legions in light order and
the heavy baggage left behind in camp
and surprised the enemy adorned by
capturing that very position
where mithridates once fought his
successful action
against triarius to this spot he ordered
the slaves to bring from the camp
all the accumulated material for the
rampart so that none of his troops
should quit their work of fortification
since the intervening valley which
separated the enemy's camp
from the emplacements which caesar had
begun was not more than a mile
wide on suddenly observing this
situation at dawn
farnasis drew up all his forces in front
of the camp
caesar was not deterred from keeping the
remainder of his army engaged on the
work of fortification
deploying only the front line in front
of the palisade
varnasis however took it into his head
to engage
whether it was the lucky associations of
the spot that drove him to this course
or the small number of our troops which
according to his information
was standing to arms or maybe even it
was his confidence in that veteran army
of his
which as his envoys boasted had fought
and conquered upon 2
and 20 battlefields having decided to
engage
he began the descent down the steep
ravine
for some little time caesar laughed
contemptuously at this empty bravado on
the part of the king
and at his troops packed closely on
ground which no enemy in his senses
would be likely to set foot on
while in the meantime farnasis with his
forces in battle array
proceeded to climb the steep hillside
confronting him
at the same steady pace at which he had
descended the sheer ravine
caesar recalled his troops from their
work of fortification ordered them to
stand to arms
deployed his legions to meet the attack
and formed a line of battle
and the sudden excitement to which all
this gave rise
occasioned considerable panic among our
troops
disorganized as our men were and as yet
in no regular formation
the king's chariots armed with scythes
threw them into confusion
but these chariots were speedily
overwhelmed by a mass of missiles
in their wake came the enemy line the
battle cry was raised
and the conflict joined our men being
greatly helped by the nature of the
ground
but above all by the blessing of the
immortal gods
heavy and bitter hand-to-hand fighting
took place and it was on the right wing
where the veteran's sixth legion was
posted that the first seeds of victory
were sown
as the enemy were being thrust back down
the slope on this wing
so too on the left wing and in the
center
the entire forces of the king were being
crushed
the ease with which they had climbed the
uneven ground was now matched
by the speed with which once dislodged
from their footing
the unevenness of the ground enabled
them to be driven back
consequently after sustaining many
casualties
some killed some knocked out by their
comrades falling on top of them
those whose nimbleness did enable them
to escape
nonetheless threw away their arms and so
after crossing the valley they could not
make any effective stand from the higher
ground
unarmed as they now were our men on the
contrary
elited by their victory did not hesitate
to climb the uneven ground
and storm the entrenchments
in his pontic triumph caesar displayed
among the showpieces of the procession
an inscription of but three words
i came i saw i conquered
not indicating the events of the war as
the others did
but the speed with which it was finished
[Music]
for now it was that the roman general
came and led his army against
eliasa and though sikari who held the
fortress masada
together with him for the whole country
adjoining
he presently gained it and put garrisons
into the most proper places of it
he also built a wall quite round the
entire fortress
that none of the besieged might easily
escape
he also set his men to guard the several
parts of it
he also pitched his camp in such an
agreeable place
as he had chosen for the siege and at
which place the rock belonging to the
fortress did make the nearest approach
to the neighboring mountain which yet
was a place of difficulty
for getting plenty of provisions for it
was not only food that was to be brought
from a great distance
and this with a great deal of pain to
those poor jews who were appointed for
that purpose
but water was also to be brought for the
camp because the place afforded no
fountain that was near it
since therefore the roman commander
silva had now built a wall on the
outside
round about this whole place as we have
said already and had thereby made a most
accurate provision
to prevent any of the besieged running
away
he undertook the siege itself
though he found but one single place
that would admit the banks he was to
raise
for behind that tower which secured the
road that led to the palace
and to the top of the hill from the west
there was a certain
eminency of the rock very broad and very
prominent
but 300 cubits beneath the highest part
of masada it was called the white
promontory accordingly he got upon that
part of rock
and ordered the army to bring earth and
when they fell to that work with
alacrity
and abundance of them together the bank
was raised
and became solid for 200 cubits in
height
yet was not this bank thought
sufficiently high for the use of the
engines that were to be set upon it
but still another elevated work of great
stones
compacted together was raised upon the
bank
this was 50 cubits both in breadth and
height
the other machines that were now got
ready were like to those that had been
first devised by vespasian
and afterwards by titus for sieges
there was also a tower made of the
height of 60 cubits
and all over plated with iron
out of which the romans threw darts and
stones from the engines
and soon made those that fought from the
walls of the place to retire
and would not let them lift up their
heads above the works
at the same time silva ordered that the
great
battering ram which he had made to be
brought thither
and to be set against the wall and to
make frequent batteries against it
which with some difficulty broke down a
part of the wall
and quite overthrew it however the
sakari made haste
and presently built another wall within
that which should not be liable to the
same misfortune from the machines
with the other it was made soft and
yielding
and so was capable of avoiding the
terrible blows that affected the other
when silva saw this he thought it best
to endeavor the taking of this wall
by setting fire to it
so he gave the order that the soldiers
should throw a great number of burning
torches upon it accordingly as it was
chiefly made of wood
it soon took fire and when it was once
set on fire
its hollowness made that fire spread to
a mighty flame
now at the very beginning of this fire a
north wind
that then blew proved terrible to the
romans
for by bringing the flame downward it
drove upon them
and they were almost in despair of
success as fearing their machines would
be burnt
but after this on a sudden the wind
changed into the south as if it were
done by
divine providence and blew strongly the
contrary way
and carried the flame and drove it
against the wall
which was now on fire through its entire
thickness
so the romans having now assistance from
god
returned to their camp with joy and
resolved to attack their enemies the
very
next day on which occasion they set
their watch more carefully that night
lest any of the jews should run away
from them without being discovered
however neither did eliezer once think
of flying away
nor would he permit anyone else to do so
but when he saw their wall burnt down by
the fire
and could not devise no other way of
escaping or room for their further
courage
and setting before their eyes what the
romans would do to them
their children and their wives he
consulted
about having them all slain
[Music]
when we marched on from this place the
persians since their frequent losses
made them dread regular battles with the
infantry
late ambushes and secretly attended us
from the
high hills on both sides watching our
companies as they marched
so that the soldiers all day long
neither raised a palisade
nor fortified themselves with stakes
and while the flanks were strongly
protected and the army as the nature of
the ground made necessary advanced in
square formation
but with the battalions in open order it
was reported to the emperor who even
then
unarmed had gone forward to investigate
that the rear guard
had suddenly been attacked from behind
excited by the misfortune
he forgot his coat of mail and merely
caught up a shield in the confusion
but as he was hastening to bring aid to
those in the rear he was recalled
by another danger the news that the van
which he had just left was just as badly
off
while he was hastening to restore order
there without regard to his own peril
a parthian band of mailed cavalry on
another side
attacked the center companies and
quickly overflowed the left wing
which gave way since our men could
hardly endure the smell and
trumpeting of the elephants
but while the emperor rushed hither and
this among the foremost ranks of the
combatants
and as the persians turned in flight
they hacked
at their legs and backs and those of the
elephants
julianus careless of his own safety
shouting and
raising his hands tried to make it clear
to the men that the enemy had fled in
disorder
and to rouse them to a still more
furious pursuit
rushed boldly into the fight his guards
who had
scattered their alarm were crying to him
from all sides to get clear of the mass
of fugitives
as dangerous as the fall of a badly
built roof when
suddenly no one knows when a
cavalryman's spear
grazed the skin of his arm pierced his
ribs
and lodged in the lower lobe of his
liver
while he was trying to pluck this out
with his right hand he felt that the
sinews of his fingers
were cut through on both sides by the
sharp steel
then he fell from his horse all present
hastened to the spot
he was taken to the camp and given
medical treatment
and soon as the pain diminished somewhat
he ceased to fear
and fighting with great spirit against
death he called for his arms
and his horse in order by his return to
the fight to restore the confidence of
his men
and troubling nothing about himself to
show that he was filled
with great anxiety for the safety of the
others
but since giuliani's strength was not
equal to his will
and he was weakened by the great loss of
blood he lay still
having lost all hope for his life
because
on inquiry he learned that the place
where he had fallen
was called phrygia for he had heard that
it was fate's decree
that he should die there
but when the emperor had been taken to
his tent the soldiers
burning with wrath and grief with
incredible vigor
rushed to avenge him clashing their
spears against their shields
resolved even to die if it should be the
will of fate
and although the high clouds of dust
blinded the eyes
and the burning heat weakened the
activity of their limbs
yet as though discharged by the loss of
their leader
without sparing themselves they rushed
upon the swords of the enemy
on the other hand the exalting persians
sent forth such a shower of arrows
that they prevented their opponents from
seeing the bowmen
before them slowly marched the elephants
which with their huge size of body
and horrifying crests struck terror into
horses
and men further off the trampling of the
combatants
the groans of the falling the panting of
the horses
and the ring of arms were heard until
finally
both parties were weary of inflicting
wounds and the darkness of night
ended the battle
on that day 50 persian grandes and
satraps fell
besides a great number of common
soldiers
[Music]
while these things were happening in
jebus a dreadful rumor came from the
west
rome had been besieged and its citizens
had been forced
to buy their lives with gold then thus
despoiled
they had been besieged again so as to
lose not their substance only
but their lives
my voice sticks in my throat and as i
dictate
sobs choke my utterance the city
which had taken the whole world itself
was
taken namor famine was beforehand with
the sword
and but few citizens were left to be
made captives
in their frenzy the starving people had
recourse
to hideous food and tore each other limb
from limb
that they might have flesh to eat
even the mother did not spare the babe
at her breast
[Music]
don't forget use the link in the
description to play conflict of nations
and get 13 000 gold and a month of
premium subscription for free
join a huge community of millions of
players in the game and
discord choose a country and fight your
way
to victory